hi my name is julius kovacic and i'm
gonna show you how i clean every opening
of an iphone
well usually the charging port gathers
the biggest amount of dust and and
pocket lane because it's just kind of
the deepest opening and
and whatever gets in there it gets
packed with the charger every time you
plug it in so in charging ports it would
usually be pocket lint and and dust
sometimes cookie crumbs or
i don't know pizza crumbs
over the time you would start getting
this is charging uh later on you have to
keep the
charger at a certain angle to get the
phone to charge
the process of cleaning charging ports
is very simple uh i use a dental pick
same thing the thing that dentists use
goes at an angle
so when they look
through the microscope i can still see
inside the port when the dental pick is
there the charging is back to normal
when you when you plug in the charging
cable you have to feel and hear like a
nice click
so in the speakers it would usually be
skin oil something greasy mixed with
dust and
very similar to ear wax on the left is
just a microphone on the right is
speaker and the microphone
[Music]
with a short brush i kind of try to just
break down whatever is in there in the
speaker mesh and then i use a regular
vacuum cleaner to to suck the rest of
the liquid out
well on the mute switch it yeah it would
usually be dust and maybe moisture kinda
as well some skin grease or hand cream
something like that getting in there and
attracting that dust and yeah i often
see
mutes which is not working stuck in
hopefully in the
in like a normal ringer mode not in a
silent one customers
never really asked to repair their mute
switch even though it doesn't work and
stuck in one position i'm not sure
whether they don't use it or they're
happy as it is but they
are happy to hear that it's fixed i use
the same
dental pick and uh and the little brush
and the outer roll but really some
that's the safest one to clean so if
somebody needs to clean this at home
just uh just
use a short brush a toothbrush would do
and
just brush it and then
it should be perfect
so in the earpiece
it would usually be
skin oils mixed with dust or or makeup
really looks and feels similar to ear
wax over the time the earpiece volume
just gets lower and lower and just
end up in this stage where
you just have to use hands-free or
earphones to to actually
make a call so to clean an earpiece i
use just a short
short brush a drop of isopropyl alcohol
and a vacuum cleaner so i put a drop on
of alcohol on the on the speaker grill
and
just kind of break break everything down
with the
with the brush and
try to remove everything what's left
there with
just a regular home vacuum cleaner so
yeah it
makes a huge difference
[Music]
customer
customers can't believe that they're
like regular
regular people phones they they can't
imagine who would be able to use it like
that
but
but they are regular people with phones
like every other phone is like this you
know so uh the owner of the phone they
do have their own life they do have
their own problems and uh there are more
bigger problems on the in people's lives
than
than their phones you know
[Music]
[Music]
you